i think one of the essential
skills of being a good coach is
listening
and this is a skill that is not taught
in school we don't learn it on home and
unfortunately and
and we don't learn it at work
listening is not hearing the words that
are spoken that's like my favorite quote
that you say go ahead i'm sorry
listening is
i thought i was being original
the
the
listening listening is not about hearing
the words that are spoken it's not being
able to parrot back what somebody said
to you listening is listening for
meaning right
you uh uh
you are a good listener
the test for being a good listener is if
the other person feels heard
right say that again right write that
down so so i mean we've all had we just
take it out of the context of business
right we've all had an argument
or wanted to share our feelings with a
friend or a loved one right spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you're sitting on
the couch and you say something's
bugging you and you say can i just tell
you something that's bugging me and they
respond by trying to fix it or they
respond by pointing out the facts that
may or may not align with how you feel
right well that's impossible because
this is what happened
and what they're missing is you are not
looking for them you're not looking for
them to compare the facts of what's
being said you just want to feel heard
you just want somebody to go oh my god
that's really hard yeah i hear it i hear
that thank you for sharing that with me
that must be difficult
thank you that's all i needed right
i'll give you a a a a very funny example
of bad listening so i used to date um a
girl who's an air traffic controller air
traffic controllers are a breed unto
themselves and it's only about the facts
and i woke up one morning i had
something in my eye and i couldn't open
my eye it was hurting and i'm like
flushing it out with water and nothing's
worked and i mean i couldn't even open
my eye come on like come here come here
i'm like look in my eye what do you see
anything junior same thing and she looks
in she goes like this and she goes
there's nothing there and then walks
away
and i eventually you know whatever it
was i eventually was okay and i went up
to her i was like
wtf right
i'm like i had something in my eye you
just walked away
and she's like there was nothing there
so what do you want me to do
i was like a little sympathy she's like
well that's not gonna get anything out
of your eye
listening is standing by my side while
i'm flushing it out with water and go oh
my god that must hurt so much yeah it
does thank you right that's listening
and
if somebody can learn to listen
and now now this is where it gets
actionable this is not me just waxing
philosophical and telling funny stories
about listening my friend will gudera do
how many of you are
or restaurant people have you ever heard
of 11 madison park so at some point in
new york city 11 madison park was the
best
restaurant in the world right ranked
number one and will believes in this he
was the former owner he believes in this
concept of unreasonable hospitality
which is going to what good services and
then going way way way beyond and one of
the core tenets of unreasonable
hospitality is learning to listen and
i'll give you an example that directly
impacts your business most agents don't
listen
and i'll give you an example what do you
do
what do you do for your clients after
they close on a home right it's very
common we've all
we've all bought a home too right which
is you walk into this new home that you
just bought as a as a buyer
and there's a bottle of champagne in the
fridge
there's a basket of flowers on the
dining room table
the same basket of flowers that you gave
to every other client the same bottle of
champagne that you gave to every client
generic
i'm a number
it's just it's just rote but if you were
listening
while they were looking at all those
homes and they saw this one little room
that was too small to make a bedroom it
was just sort of a stupid little nook
that nobody really understood why that
room existed in the house and your
client walked and goes i could make this
my yoga room and that's the house they
bought
instead of putting a bottle of champagne
in the house this is what will talks
about instead of putting a bottle of
champagne in the fridge why not put a
yoga mat
in that room
with a little note that says it's
perfect
right
that's called listening
and every single time you go out
[Applause]
every single time you go out with
clients
uh
they are telling you things they're
telling you stories they're waxing
philosophical they're telling you what
they don't like and what they do like
the problem is you're listening to
whether they like big windows you're
listening to whether they like the view
you're listening to whether they have
two cars and they need three cars or
whatever it is but you're not listening
to the reasons why the why you're not
listening for the meaning
and that's those are the little notes
you want to make that make someone feel
seen and make someone feel heard